sochaux revient et contrairement aux
apparences il n'a pas changé toujours
jamais contents a étalé ses bobos nos
bourbourg devant les illusions perdues
son chant dit sa lassitude des jambons
riche et bien portant des magazines
on y paul loup sulitzer
c'est le vide c'est à dire que l'on
vient de passer dix ans de vide on
aboutit à voir tous les jours un
magazine nouveau avec une fille qui dit
jamais rien on sait pas ce qu'elle est
ce qu'elle pense qu elle ce qu'elle dit
du monde et on ne sait pas c'est dur
pour les femmes d'abord et puis pour les
hommes aussi parce qu'elle voudra pas
couché avec nous je le sens bien
sous son lit c'est arlette laguiller qui
donc faire une chasse on
et
elle est là une pureté
elle a quelque chose d' authentiques qui
est très rare on rencontre chez l'abbé
pierre et et puis c'est tout
douillet
dix chansons pour dire leur gré du temps
10 passes et 10 souchon tour à tour
drôles ou mélancolique plus décontracté
peut-être mais toujours aussi désabusé
sa rébellion rigolard de nous manquer et
cbi chanson là c'est déjà ça
la blancheur qu'on croyait